okay I just want to just highlight your
attention to things like every day I get
the MIT news feed I get a couple of
other news feeds and I just thought this
was really sort of a striking image and
I think a great way to convey science
and engineering is through sort of
really eye-catching imagery and this but
these are this is a synapse which is
where nerves contact our other nerves or
to the neuromuscular Junction in order
to trigger activity and this is a piece
of research out of the Seema whoops go
back one oops go back one more between
the FEMA and Langer labs where they've
designed a little tiny microchip probes
they're about 10 microns big that can be
planted in the brain in different sites
non hopefully non invasively but and
they could report on concentrations of
this neurotransmitter dopamine and the
reason you might want to be able to do
that is that there is a dopamine deficit
in a lot of neurologic disorders so you
would like to understand what the
deficits are and pinpoint points of the
brain where there may be issues and in
fact they used it to track Parkinson's
disease because Parkinson's disease some
of the therapeutic approaches involve
deep brain stimulation but you can't
really tell if it's working unless you
can measure something and the thing that
you could measure would be the absolute
levels of this neurotransmitter dopamine
which by the way is originated from the
amino acid tyrosine you could sort of
spot some of the parts of that that
would be the carbon becomes a cotton is
a carboxylate and an amine
oh I've drawn I've drawn the alcohol
this should be an nh-2 group sorry I
just added this at last minute so
dopamine actually though originates from
tyrosine so I just thought you would be
interested because when I talk about
highlighting things that are in the news
I mean
things like this where we're all kind of
interesting it's cool it's relevant to
what we do and it really combines the
efforts of scientists and engineers to
make tools and methods and invent
methods to make measurements that are
quantitative enough to guide the
analysis of a disorder so I just want to
wrap up a little bit on the aspects I'm
showing you the energy diagrams in the
last class and telling you how enzymes
affect the course of a reaction by
lowering the energy of activation by
stabilizing a transition state or a high
energy intermediate state so the energy
of activation becomes smaller in the
catalyzed reaction therefore faster than
in the other catalysts reaction and I
did not give you this number last time
enzymes catalyze reactions through about
10 to the 6 a million to 10 to the 10
folds so these are dramatic increases in
rates that are really fizzy we depend on
physiologically they ensure specificity
and they're essential in all systems and
the way we discuss energetic changes in
reaction diagrams is by looking at
what's known as the Delta G it's the
change in free energy what I show you
here is an exergonic reaction where it
is a negative Delta G I didn't reinforce
that point in that last time the energy
of the products is lower than the energy
of the substrates so energy is given out
at the end of the transformation that
means the reaction is favorable with
respect to an equilibrium a
thermodynamic parameter and then it's
the enzyme that takes care of the
kinetic aspects of the reaction so just
to sort of show you the correlate an
endergonic reaction would look like this
where the Delta G is positive the
products are less stable than the
starting materials which would mean the
reaction is not favourable but it will
still proceed in the presence of a
catalyst
and in this next small bit where we talk
about pathways and different aspects of
metabolism I'm going to tell you how we
get around the unfavorable equilibrium
problem because that's obviously a big
predicament in biochemistry if reactions
aren't favorable why do they why do they
go far enough to be useful to us in in
metabolism and so that reaction would
have a positive Delta G and then I also
mentioned these two terms anabolic
refers to the end argon the endergonic
reactions I don't know why you're doing
this to me the endergonic reactions and
catabolic refers to the exergonic
reactions okay then this last point I
showed you this slide last time but I
think it was important to think about
why our enzyme so big and I want to give
you some example of an additional
genetic mutation that causes a human
disorder where I at least show you how
the mutations are spread quite a
distance from the reaction center to
show you that all of that structure that
you see in an enzyme as it interacts
with a small substrate is critical for
catalysis so we see small substrates in
each case but we have this very large
enzyme which is many many times its size
all engaged in catalysis but what's the
proof of that so why are enzyme so big
so phenylketonuria is human disorder
it's one of those disorders that
neonates Brad newborns are tested for
they they're checked for the genetic
signal that shows that the protein will
have mutations in its structure and
there are many mutations associated with
a defect in this particular protein and
the protein that I'm talking about is
phenylalanine hydroxylase so the
disorder is related to defects in
phenylalanine hydroxylase now what does
that enzyme do it takes phenylalanine
and installs a hydroxyl group opposite
to where it's attached to the amino acid
so this is the hydrophobic amino acid
phenylalanine and this is another one of
the hydrophobic amino acids in a similar
family that's tyrosine and in fact it's
the precursor to dopamine
physiologically now it turns out in this
kid there can always be too much of a
good thing so if you have too much
phenylalanine it has to be converted to
a different amino acid because the build
up of phenylalanine gets to a certain
stage where it is converted itself to a
toxic by-product that actually causes
severe mental disorders and seizures so
you need to the body needs to monitor
the levels of phenylalanine and at a
certain stage phenylalanine hydroxylase
will convert it to tyrosine so even
though phenylalanine is essential
too much phenylalanine is a bad thing so
that enzyme is the one that is
associated with defects that with
mutations that lower the activity of the
phenylalanine hydroxylase and end you up
accumulating phenylalanine to high and
so the pah regulates the clearance from
the body converting it to tyrosine so
why you know I just I told you I would
give you some insight into how entire
enzymes are in fact critical for
catalysis so what I'm showing you on
this little movie is that the sites
shown in magenta all around this protein
the active site would be where this big
ball is it's actually cofactor iron but
the sites that are involved in the
reduction of activity of phenylalanine
hydroxylase away out on the protein out
on its perimeters so this protein is
about 49 angstroms 4.9 nanometers across
but the sites that cause a reduction in
activity are a long way away 10
angstroms longer 15 angstroms 16 so it
turns out that enzymes as catalysts
don't just use the local environment
right near where chemistry happens the
entire protein collaborates to make the
changes happen in catalysis so enzymes
are big because you're not just using
this inner shell of functional groups
where the substrate binds you're
actually using a lot of the dynamics of
the enzyme to promote catalysis and just
this sort of visual shows you how far
away things can be where they suppress
the activity of a protein and make it a
poor a catalyst okay so as I said this
is one of the dis disorders that the
genetic mutations that tested is tested
for at birth if you have one of these
set of mutations you immediately have to
be put on a diet that's low in
phenylalanine so you don't bombard your
body with too much phenylalanine
allowing this is not allowing the
phenylalanine to build up too much but
there I don't know if any of you have
lately grabbed a can of coca-cola that's
got a Spartan as a sweetener it turns
out that sweetener nutrasweet rather is
a dipeptide see but it contains
phenylalanine so if you drink a ton of
diet drinks that include a nutrasweet
you are actually bombing yourself with
high levels of phenylalanine that the
body can't deal with so people who have
phenylketonuria ie a defect in that
enzyme shouldn't be drinking or using
NutraSweet type sweeteners because they
actually give you too much penile
alanine at once that you can't mitigate
the levels of so I want to just tell you
about these genetic disorders there's a
fairly decent set that are tested for a
birth but the ones that are tested are
the ones that you can make dietary
modifications or lifestyle modifications
and mitigate the the symptoms and so
that's a very important thing to know
you're not tested for things you don't
know how to fix because that wouldn't be
that wouldn't be appropriate alright any
questions about that
yeah oh you know that was me being
clunky with her because you guys notice
everything this morning I was
making everybody let's go forward
learned and that and I know what I know
exactly what you're talking about this
little curve down yeah that's that's me
shaking when I'm doing the Kendra or
drawing it should be a flat but thank
you for noticing that just so that's not
ambiguous there should not be there
could be actually a little dip when
substrates bind to enzymes but I didn't
mean to imply it okay anything else okay
so what I want to talk about now is the
equilibrium problem and what is that
so if we have reactions that are
endergonic so we have one of these
situations where we have a substrate
going to a product that's higher energy
what that means is at equilibrium
between substrate and product which is
defined by the Delta G you have
substrate going to product but mostly
you've got a lot of substrate there
which is the amount of each of these is
defined by this energy difference okay
so how do we survive with these kinds of
transformations when we really want the
flux through an enzyme to be in the
forwards direction because if we need
the product we need to move things
forward so nature deals with this by
coupling reactions to other reactions so
it finds ways around the equilibrium
problem by for example putting a series
of reactions for example let's go from A
to B to C so these are three
intermediates catalyzed by enzyme one
enzyme to okay and let's just say this
has an unfavorable Delta G so we don't
make we have a lot of a we have very
little B
and then what happens how are we gonna
and then let's just say for example this
reaction is favorable all right so let's
say the Delta G here is positive the
Delta G here is negative all right so by
plus bei mean positive and negative so
this is a favorable reaction whereas
this is an unfavorable reaction how does
putting two reactions adjacent to each
other
happening on the same substrate moving
through helped that situation yeah
perfect so the answer here is that as
you take whatever B you have and turn it
into C a has a has the e one has to make
more B so you solve the equilibrium
problem in that way to a certain extent
by just opening the tap at the other end
of the series a nature organizes a ton
of reactions in sequential pathways to
get around these kinds of problems so
this is done by coupling reactions and
so there are some reactions that are
highly favorable highly exothermic where
you can really sort of guarantee flux
through that enzyme a lot of these
enzymes are ATP dependent they use and
burn ATP so you get a lot of energy out
and they drive the flux through enzyme
one by enzyme to being an exergonic
reaction while enzyme one is endergonic
so flux is guaranteed and a lot of
pathways sort of set up to be in this
way with this coupling of the
chemistry's so what we find is that
enzymes
first of all work in pathways where they
are co-located in certain places they
may be for example who localized to
certain organelles in a human cell they
may be Co localized in the mitochondria
or in some organelle and we'll talk more
about organelles and mitochondria later
they could be Co localized at a membrane
and so you ensure that the enzymes are
together by putting them in the same
place and then nature also evolves ways
where the enzymes physically interact
with each other either covalently or
non-covalently so they could be
associated in the pathway by some kind
of non covalent interaction or you may
actually link enzymes to make them
single species so if this is enzyme one
and this is enzyme 2 here you have an
enzyme one enzyme two single long
polypeptide chain that has two domains
they can't get away from each other
because they're joined covalently and
they catalyze sequential reactions this
just doesn't happen with just three
enzymes it can happen with ten enzymes
or more so they're very clever ways to
ensure the plucks occurs through
pathways but don't forget all along that
each of these enzymes is responsible for
a single transformation that's important
there's another phenomenon that having
flux through pathways is very useful for
is to deal with toxic intermediates
because that makes it very advantageous
again to couple reactions so let's say
product B is toxic
we don't want it hanging around much we
don't want it released from an enzyme to
go do damage somewhere in the cell
so having flux through a pathway
basically ensures the B never gets out
of the game it just goes straight to
enzyme 2 so that's another another
physical advantage of those processes
being linked together and finally the
process also ensures a very nice
opportunity to do regulation so here we
on this slide I show you this sort of
mega mess of metabolic pathways in
physiology that there would be the
critter the krebs cycle but all the
metabolic pathways that are all
interlinked and many of these pathways
will be Co localized but steps in these
pathways will be Co localized as
clusters and so that deals tells you how
we can solve the equilibrium problem by
linking enzymes for flux through
pathways and one of the best examples is
in aerobic glycolysis we're in the early
steps they're not energetically
favorable you use ATP to start to break
down glucose then you get to a certain
intermediate where it's conversion to a
smaller molecule generates ATP with very
favorable reactions so glycolysis is a
really great example of this now the
other thing that I just want to describe
to you is the issue of feedback and I
describe this here on this slide and so
we'll talk about it on this slide so if
we are working with a pathway that goes
through multiple steps to make an end
product five steps three steps over here
and you've made too much of that you've
already made a lot of that product and
you don't need anymore nature also has
in place a regulatory mechanism to
feedback and stop slot
through the pathway you don't just stop
all the enzymes you find a way to stop
the first enzyme so this is a very
important paradigm in biochemistry and
that's called negative feedback so I'm
showing you it here just in a very
simple cartoon form in the isoleucine
biosynthesis pathway that's one of the
hydrophobic amino acids this is an
intermediate that is on its way from
this amino acid that is polar but not
charged threonine so threonine gets
converted to isoleucine we need
threonine to make isoleucine but once we
got a lot of isoleucine it binds to the
very first enzyme in the pathway and
acts as an arrow low steric regulator
that dampens activity so in this case I
just want to point out to you that I'm
showing a very common way we know tape
things when we are talking about
inhibiting a reaction we draw it like
this we align and then align to the so
the arrow just which means you've
stopped the activity so you'll see this
again and again you're gonna see it a
lot in signaling pathways because things
often feedback so another thing that
nature ensures in additions are not
building up toxic products and dealing
with the equilibria is that you don't
want a ton of enzymes working to make
something you don't need anymore so you
might as well take the end product and
use it to stop the first enzyme as that
end product becomes scarce it
dissociates from the first enzyme and it
turns the pathway back on again and I
think that's a really neat way of making
that happen and also in these cases the
enzymes have to be clustered as a group
because you wouldn't get those local
concentrations to be so advantageous if
the enzymes weren't co-localize does
that make sense if they weren't in a
really near location that enzyme that
pursuit produces isoleucine that
isoleucine couldn't bind back to the
first enzyme in the pathway if they were
in different compartments of the cell
okay everyone good with that
good alright okay so now we are moving
on to carbohydrates it's a pretty
strange word carbohydrate but actually
it relates to early findings that
glucose is a carbohydrate and its
molecular formula is c6h12o6 so they
called it a hydrate of carbon before
when they knew the elemental composition
but they didn't know anything about the
structure there's a lot of carbohydrates
that don't be hey doughnut BAE this rule
but that's where the name comes from a
hydrate of carbon all right now
carbohydrates are account for what do
they have here
25% of the mass of macromolecules so a
good amount there are very very
important carbohydrates in central
metabolism we use carbohydrates as a
source of energy but also carbohydrates
a part of storage of energy in the form
of polymeric structures that I'll
describe to you there are different ones
in plants and in humans
one is glycogen one is cellulose but
carbohydrates have an increasingly
important role in the extracellular
matrix in these polymers that are
wrapped around your cells and also a
signaling entities both inside and
outside the cell so we used to think of
carbohydrates and straightaway connect
this with metabolism but the story is
far greater than that and I'll try to
explain to you why and it's because of
the richness of functional groups in a
carbohydrate so the simplest
carbohydrate before I go up there
is a three carbon molecule this would
actually be called glyceraldehyde but
don't worry about that other name for it
it's a three carbon carbohydrate and
this molecule would be called a triose
so we've got a couple of new a new
suffix because anything that there's a
carbohydrate ends with the suffix OSE
not to be confused with the suffix ASE
which is an enzyme so look carefully
whether it's an A or an O because it's
the difference between a big protein
that catalyzes a reaction and a
carbohydrate so a triose would be a
carbohydrate with three carbons they
have an aldehyde or let's just say they
have a carbonyl functionality so
remember the that there would be lone
pair electrons on those OHS similarly on
these and remember that each of these
vertices corresponds to a carbon it's
some the way you recognize carbohydrates
is most commonly is that they are rich
in carbon - o H bonds which are
hydroxyls which makes them polar
molecules likely to be highly so baited
in water and very different for the from
the compounds that are rich in just CH
bonds that don't have such opportunities
so if you see a molecule and it's got a
bunch of CHS but not a bunch of OHS it's
probably a lipid if you see a com a
compound that's rich in OHS it's likely
to be a carbohydrate the story gets a
little bit more interesting as we move
up to some of the different
carbohydrates which I've shown you there
on that screen and I'm going to go
forward to talk about those because this
triose is important in primary
metabolism
we break down carbon carbohydrates that
have six sugars to small carbohydrates
that have three excuse me
carbohydrates that have six carbons two
carbohydrates that have three carbons
and that's where these three carbon
entities crop up but I want to focus you
in on two sets of carbohydrates the
hexoses and the pentoses so we
immediately know their carbohydrates
right OSE the hexoses obviously has six
carbons and the pentoses have five
carbons and these are the most important
of the carbohydrates yes there are
carbohydrates with four carbons and then
there were ones with seven eight nine
carbons but these are the ones we'll
totally focus on in 701 six because
these are very important in different
biopolymers and hexoses are important
components for example of cellulose and
glycogen but where are the pentose
carbons where are they so important
actually I need to draw this as it's
straight chain inversion cuz I'll Drive
you crazy
so this sugar here is a pentose one two
three four five carbons bunch of OHS
aldehyde at one end commonly
carbohydrates will fold up into a cyclic
structure through an equilibrium I won't
worry you too much with the chemistry
but I'm just gonna show you that
structure looks like this a five
membered ring so this the inter
conversion of these two is an
equilibrium process and those
carbohydrates are incredibly important
where yeah
nucleic acids so your phosphodiester
backbone is attached to sugars that are
attached to better to purines and
pyrimidines and we'll see those
structures later but an absolutely
essential feature of that polymer is
this five membered ring carbohydrates
that are known as ribose which is what
that guy is and two deoxyribose where
one of the hydroxyls is actually a
hydrogen it's not a hydroxyl and it's
this one so instead of being a no H it's
a an H and we number carbohydrates and
your I'll reinforce this much more when
we talk about carbohydrate about nucleic
acids there's a numbering system so two
deoxyribose is in your DNA and ribose
itself is in your RNA okay so obviously
we need to worry about carbohydrates and
learn a little bit about them based on
that key criterion okay let's move now
to the hexoses I'm not gonna make you
keep drawing hexoses and things I'm
gonna just to tell you a little bit
about them with respect to their
structures so I've shown you on the
board the cyclic form of a pentose this
is the linear form and the cyclic form
let me write that down
and by the way in your DNA it's always
in the cyclic form it's not in the
linear form and the hexoses also have a
linear in a cyclic form and I show you
that equilibrium for glucose you see six
carbons I've got them numbered and they
form favorably into the six membered
ring this is the cyclic form of glucose
this is the linear form of glucose when
glucose associates into polymers it
becomes these things like cellulose or
glycogen and
depends a lot on the linkages and those
polymers to define which one it is now
as I mentioned carbohydrates aren't
always just a series of Oh H groups
there sometimes are the functionality so
I'm just going to quickly draw those and
if you've got them on your handout you
can play along with me here so sometimes
there's an nh-2 there that's called
glucosamine very creatively sometimes
that NH 2 is converted to an amide like
that bond in a peptide so it's glucose a
bit right and sometimes so you can draw
these on your handout because the six
membered rings are there this stays as a
no H but this Oh H here is that a
different oxidation state don't worry
about that terminology but what's
important
it's glucuronic acid so it can be
negatively charged positively charged
neutral so there are variations on a lot
of our hexoses basically meaning this
carbohydrate molecular formula doesn't
work anymore but the term is stuck all
right
so there's quite a variety of different
carbohydrates with slight differences
and the intriguing thing is that the
carbohydrates that you and I use in all
of our physiologic processes are much
simpler than the carbohydrates the
bacteria use there's an expansion of
like 10 to the 2 or 10 to the 3 in the
variety of sugars that bacteria use and
that's definitely a story for another
day so let me now move on to thinking
about carbohydrates not as the monomers
that you metabolize but rather as the
polymers that are involved in many other
different types of processes and when we
think about the polymers we want to
think about how they're polymers differ
from the polymers
of nucleic acids or proteins because
this will tell you why carbohydrates are
so complicated right when you may take a
bunch of amino acids and make a polymer
it's a linear polymer right every unit
is joined to the next by an ami there's
no branching there it's just a linear
polymer so the diversity is not enormous
or it's pretty enormous but it's not as
big as it could be if it were a branched
polymer with different types of side
chains we will see next week that the
polymers of the nucleic acids here's the
basic structure there's the ribose by
the way the R could be an OHA char NH
attached to a base a purine or
pyrimidine you don't need to know that
yet you'll know it next week and then to
a phosphate but those again are linear
polymers you only have you don't have
branching you just have a single
continuous chain the crazy thing about
sugars is they can branch from any of
those OHS so there's much more diversity
of structure and function within with
wrapped in the carbohydrates which makes
them real trouble to study okay I want
to now introduce you to another feature
the other thing is when we join amino
acids or we join nucleic acid building
blocks nuclear sides there's no
difference in the shapes that we can
form we don't have variety there but in
sugars we can make different kinds of
linkages depending on how to O H groups
in a sugar are joined so for example if
you join two glucose Asst in this kind
of linkage that would give you maltose
but if you join two glucoses in that
kind of linkage it would give you
lactose and those are different
compounds they serve different types of
physiologic roles and there are enzymes
that will make these bonds and then
enzymes the world break these bonds
there is a common disorder that people
have as they grow older the enzyme that
breaks the lactase the lactose bond the
gets turned off it doesn't work anymore
and that's the enzyme lactose so when
people
intolerance to sugars lactose is the
sugar in milk and they can't digest
dairy products because lactase doesn't
work anymore or you can take supplements
so that's how that relates to physiology
the reaction between two glucose is to
make the disaccharide is actually a
condensation because when you join that
bond you kick out water as a side
product or when you break that bond you
release water so this is another one of
the condensation reactions so underline
that on the slide because a condensation
means a reaction that proceeds and
produces you a molecule of water okay
all right and this just sums up the
lactase problem where you can't digest
lactose the milk sugar okay so those are
monomers now let's think about polymers
and complex structures of sugars and I
put these all on the slides because it's
just impossible for you to keep drawing
them and I'm just gonna give you sort of
one of my pet peeves
I draw sugars like this a lot of other
people draw sugars like that and I don't
like that because this is what they look
like so if you see this and you go I
haven't seen sugars looking like that
before
it's because this is the way to draw
them that actually represents their
shape so if it's unusual format to you
I'm not going to ask you to construct
these I just want you to be familiar
with looking at them like this rather
than like this because to me that's the
best way to render them alright okay so
polymers of sugars I just mentioned to
you there are polymers of sugars that
are important as storage so when we have
excess glucose we store glucose as
glycogen in the liver and stored in the
liver and later on in the semester we'll
see how a bolt of adrenaline does sets
all the processes in motion to chew up
glycogen to release
more glucose so you can have a lot of
energy quickly so in that in that
polymer the sugars are linked in a
different way the common polymer in
plants and in fact accounts for a
massive proportion of the biomass is a
different polymer of glucose where the
linkages are Beatle that we would call
this a beta linkage but that's the way
it looks
and that would be cellulose and it's a
linear polymer coming down here glycogen
is often a branched polymer with
different kinds of linkages with
different aspects or different shapes so
the glycogen that we store and can break
down in order to produce glucose to make
energy as glycogen we cannot break down
cellulose we don't digest plant
cellulose because we don't have those
enzymes which is why we don't get
nutritional value out of the cellulose
the same way we can we can put the
forces in action to break down glucose
so the way those bond looks bonds look
is absolutely critical for how you can
use the energy that's within them by
using enzymes to break those bonds okay
so in general I've just said that
glucose can be stored a cellulose or as
glycogen the process of photosynthesis
converts energy and sunlight into glue
into glucose and then you can make the
polymers of glucose and what I'm showing
you here in these polymers is a
simplified view I want to introduce to
you one other term and that term is
glycan and that basically refers to
something that is more than one sugar
one carbohydrate I was looking at the
videos of my lectures I realized my
handwriting is horrible so I'm really
trying very hard to make it a little bit
neater today so glycan is just the name
for a polymer of sugars but they can
also be called
polysaccharides
but glycan now is the commonly accepted
term for a lot of sugars now I told you
about energy storage
I've told you about simple disaccharides
and monosaccharides and metabolism but
what I want to do now is give you a
little overview of all the different
places where sugars feature in a Cell
because I think it's really important to
realize that sugars form a great sort of
set of Communicator molecules for
communication so I'm gonna go around
this sort of funny-looking square cell
and this would be a eukaryotic cell
because it's got a nucleus and there are
different compartments so within the
cell the cell sits in what's known as an
extracellular matrix
it's a meshwork of sugar polymers that
actually is important for the cells and
important for trapping signals that come
from cells and go to other cells so
those are all predominantly made up of
carbohydrate the next thing to look at
is that there are sugar there are
proteins within the cell that can become
modified with a sugar and go to the
nucleus or leave the nucleus so there is
a type of signaling that is based on
adding a sugar or taking it off a
protein we'll see later in the semester
how also phosphorylation does a lot of
functions that look like that there are
sugars that are displayed on cell
surface polymers and that's where
signaling becomes important because
sugars may be attached to lipids you
remember we've talked about
phospholipids being part of the membrane
sugars can be attached to lipids that
sit in the membrane and face out and
it's how cell-cell communication occurs
in some instances or they may be
attached to proteins that are also
displayed on the surface of the cell so
this tells you a little bit about where
we put these sugars is what's
responsible for communication because
they're there on the surface and the
cell were their sides out and then the
final thing I want to talk about is the
blood group system
a lot of you may be aware of blood
groups there are four principle blood
groups and those the differences between
the blood in a B a B and O blood groups
a differences in just the sugars that
are attached to the surface of the cell
so let me describe those and then we'll
talk about blood groups and things that
are being done to enhance the supplies
of red blood cells in cases of emergency
I have a nice little video I'm hoping to
get to so on the surface of the cell you
might have different sugars this is a
trisaccharide all right you can see one
two three sugars they have different
linkages but you can pick out the sugars
and they are joined by a bond called a
glycoside bond and those join sugars so
what do you think the enzyme that
Cleaves a glycoside is like a side like
OC days you would think like us today is
I would say glycoside days but they are
the same thing so and that's gonna be
pertinent in a minute so remember if in
doubt guess and stick a's at the end if
i ask you the name of an enzyme because
that works pretty well so if you have a
blood group you would have exclusively
this trisaccharide on your red blood
cells if you have the a blood group you
have an extra sugar attached to that
trisaccharide and it's a glucosamine
glucosamine sugar there's an extra
carbonyl group with on on an amide and
if you have B blood group
it's gluco it's a sugar it's actually
called galactose that has all age groups
so the difference is between if your oh
group if you're a group or if your B
group are just those differences in
sugars and then people who have a B
blood group have a composite they have a
Mik
of the a and the B blood group all right
so yeah question that's a second marker
so and which we won't talk about but
it's uh so it's a plus a different plus
another marker that's either one type or
another type all right but the a B and O
are defined by the sugars yeah good
question okay so the people know their
blood group it's good to know
frankly because you know someone you
know you may cut yourself on someone
says do you know your blood group and
you go yes and they'll give you an
on-site transfusion and I've been
watching too much Jack Bauer but you
know that's a story for another day as
well so if so it turns out that
depending on blood groups you can either
be a universal donor or a universal
acceptor so the people with the O blood
group can give anyone their blood
people with O a B and a B but
unfortunately for the poor people with
Oh blood group is they could they cannot
receive blood from blood group a B or a
B and I wanted to show this and I hope I
can get it working because we have just
the right amount of time which makes me
really happy because I don't really
program things that well sometimes there
was a P there was um at the latest
American camera other disasters were
affected by crisis usually need for
vital things food shelter water and
blood in particular o type blood because
it can be safely given to any patient
now scientists say they have identified
enzymes from the human gut that can turn
Type A and B blood into Type O up to 30
times more efficiently than previously
studied enzymes type A or B blood has
specific sugars on the outside of itself
these sugars are recognized by the
immune system and if they don't match
the type of blood that's already in an
individual those cells are destroyed
because these sugars are recognized by
the immune system
they're called antigens type a B blood
has both antigens and type O blood has
none the researchers presented these
findings at the recent American Chemical
Society national meeting in Boston
Stephen withers from the University of
British Columbia has been
studying enzymes that remove a or b
antigens from red blood cells
if those antigens can be removed then
type A or B can be converted to type O
blood to find the enzymes more quickly
withers in a colleague at his
institution used a technique called
metagenomics which allows scientists to
sample the genes of millions of
microorganisms without the need for
individual coal so that tells you
something about technology and
engineering and understanding structures
so it would be really advantageous the
state of which you really need blood
supplies is to take all the blood in the
blood banks and turn everything into a
universal donor but the blood banks keep
these differentiated supplies of blood
but what if you needle you know you need
something that you can give everyone
safely and so there are enzymes in the
guards there excuse me bacteria in the
gut
that actually live off of sugars that
they chopped off cells in and the matrix
in the in the in the in the in GI system
and so what the withers group did was to
screen a lot of different enzymes from
bacteria in the gut and find ones that
had a really good specificity for
removing those sugars then they did
protein engineering work to make them
more efficient thus creating something
that was proposed a long time ago could
be useful but now really making it
useful because those enzymes are much
more efficient they really catalyze
reactions a great speed so they're much
more efficient engineering enzymes to
treat your blood cells to make sure you
get rid of all the features that are
characteristic of the a the B and the a
B antigens because you if you don't do a
good job of it then the human immune
system will recognize the little bits
that sneak in and start triggering an
immune response so the efficiency of the
enzymes that cleave those sugars off is
absolutely paramount and that's what I
have for you today I will see you Monday
so don't forget the P sets due at 3:00
Monday I would like for you to have a
preview of the whoops
of the DNA reading material I don't know
if any of you do this but I think it's
really handy so there's just some very
little sections and we'll give you a bit
of exposure to nucleic acids it'll just
make the lecture a little bit more kind
of familiar but that's what we're up for
Monday
you